non perderti anita stories la serie
animata un nuovo episodio ogni domenica
alle 12 sul mio canale di scarico astori
oggi nuova challenge a grandissima
richiesta se avete richiesto di fare la
challenge se indovini il prezzo telo
copri siamo pronti per uscire in più ci
sono dice marino ci sono mangiarsi
l'obiettivo della casa
io sono un bel mi piace se volete vedere
anche i video dei nobili berlino che sta
cercando di farsi vedere perché lui
vuole essere il protagonista fin dove di
quello che disegnato la comparse questo
video raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace fare
molto per quanto come funziona questo
challenge praticamente noi andremo in
giro per negozi e dovremo indovinare il
prezzo dell'oggetto senza guardare il
prezzo siamo sbagliare abbiamo un
margine di errore di 20 euro
quindi se è più di 20 euro meno di 20
euro abbiamo comunque indovinato e
possiamo comprarlo
altrimenti non possiamo comprarlo ad
aprire video fateci sapere qual è la
cosa che vi presta di più tra le cose
che abbiamo comprato fra di tale ad ora
le lavatrici adora fare le lavatrici ha
trovato la sua entrata perfetta
una super lavatrice motivo
che tutti ti piacerebbe avere questa è
la matrice a casa si fa
ok allora non guardo a guardare
no hai sbagliato non solo finita con
sono felice
non è questo
quella animale
una spiegazione
no non mi controllare i no direi 329
quindi lo stesso molto di più anche io
sinceramente allora deve indovinare il
prezzo di quello bellissimo questo qui
rosa
e io come faccio a capire favore quello
giusto perché questo è giusto devo fare
1000 1300 1300 o prove 1300 kg ok
vediamo il corsera del sopra questi n
ed in asia
le impostazioni 13 4 gb di ram o molto
chic e dell'ambiente sta risparmiando
sacco fuori di sbagliare difatti
sbagliare allora compie mondo ma da lo
scudo con la speedlite non posso
vorrebbero certo prezzo gialli c'e il
cartellino
quella di peste
ok 170 attacco di più perché tu che
dovevano 36 sbagliato italia ho trovato
degli occhiali con la musica dentro c'è
praticamente c'è la cassa fa vinse la
causa
quanto costano secondo te
340 euro
sei vicino di 100 euro insomma ma
condizione nostra condizione conduzione
ossea ad accogliere la vita
voglio provare
io pensavo ci fossero delle canzoni ai
gruppi si fa pensavo fossero condizioni
così tutti possono sentire la sua musica
è maturo sente più forte
allora vitale sta scegliendo pantaloni
quali ti piacciono
cercando un pantalone nero questo quanto
costa secondo te
io dico mettiamo il centesimo però dai
sono abbonato
prendiamo
questo musica che si muove allora
secondo me questo
30 gente
guardate una super pokémon
vediamo se poi il prezzo diverso noto
spesso più vediamo se quanto sta nemmeno
gli apple watch vediamo se l'aspetto più
bello indovinato con il prezzo di prima
quando sono impegnato giocare comune
fino partito che lingua parli pure
bassolino c'è qualcosa di strano dice
non andare mai trovato ieri
ti ricordi quando sbagliato il prezzo
delle paul watson detto 360 e invece era
400 qualcosa se certo i muri come ho
scoperto che su amazon con gli sconti
del black friday
guarda quanto costa cosa cosa fatta
questa cosa questa nazione metterà si
vede i 369 quindi il tubo talevi detto
io mangio 360 quindi posso prenderlo
perchè sono molto contento l'idea che
tutti i prezzi non sono i prezzi delle
cose ma nel frattempo vediamo le cose
che siamo riusciti a prendere
indovinando i fritti oggi
maxicar tutti i curiosi si troverà
normale in realtà magi kart è uno dei
miei pokémon preferiti perché è il
pokemon più sottovalutato di tutti
perché non fa per niente certa solo la
mostra sul e non facciano i miei
governino che diceva cosa che so cosa
rebaglio poi però poi anche se un
pokémon molto sottovalutato lui si
trasforma in ge ridosso diventa uno dei
pokemon più forti di tutti gigantesco
fortissimo quindi prende la sua
rivincita in più adesso per simpatico ma
logica wrf gara tiriamola fuori dalla
casa marino berlino si è aggiunta di
darmi quel fesso da lizzani me lo mangio
no merlino è un po ma non ti manda
poverino dai file tiriamola fuori dalla
casa così posso vederlo meglio
berlino è in agguato agitatissima fatto
siccome ancora questa va molto più
splash vediamo se non tocco di verde eni
a berlino sta impazza aspetta franco
piga meglio allontanarli marche marina
di san marino forse pensate sia un vero
paese e lo volevo già re per quello
omeopatica sbaglio e nero ma siccome
magi carto usa strass
a berlino come utenti inviati bartali il
mio nonno pantalone ma è sì perché io di
solito quanti pantaloni distruggo o
quanti jeans e distruggono bestie che
devo distruggere io a non dovete sapere
che vitale distrugge ivan taloni o
perché cade o perché propone alle porte
oppure rota e fai buchi nel mondo lo fa
ricorda marino che sta cercando di
prendere il foglio ma quella magica
quello nascosto l'asso bra perché
merlino proverà in ogni caso a prenderlo
a maggio la città cosa 5 niente di molto
il riposo ecco luca sembra una scatola
po lungo perché bianca e non c'è scritto
niente
ma andiamo ad aprirlo anzi indovinate
nei commenti scrivete adesso quando voi
di che colore l'ho scelto scrivete ora
nei commenti senza sbirciare dopo
vediamo chi ha indovinato poi ok andiamo
ad aprirlo è troppo curiosa
penso che si apre da qua metti i rumori
e smr delle felici
questa sembrava un po una sorellina di
merlino a misano
è un po strana questa cosa questa
scatola ci sono di orologi di impegnati
qua io voglio questo però mi disse lo
mettevano al contrario infatti si trova
forse questo diventa proprio una carta
da gioco forse robo allora vediamo ora
vi faccio vedere il colore viaggio
aspetta è un porto orologio come a ecco
ok
[Musica]
che bello sembra un mini iphone
vediamo il caricatore
qua ci sono tipo
le istruzioni cos'è lo leggerà mai
penalizzano legge ormai le istruzioni
che leggo sorpreso è vero e poi dopo
cosima fare questa crisi ma fare questo
è il caricatore che strano molto lungo
che questo questo è il caricatore in cui
praticamente un orologio si appoggia qua
sopra si carica berlino spazi
osservando il tutto cos'è cos'è quella
cosa posso assaggiarla fatemela
assaggiare poco poco poco poco non lo
restituisco un po masticata una bella
restituisca togliamo la pellicola
mi staccano tonta bene mi sa che non
carichiamo più questo che ricade quindi
questo è il caricatore amor a vedere la
come si dice italia nostra è arrivato a
berlino sarà in grado di inghiottire
l'orologio sono l'orologiaio notaio
allora questo è il 100 lino cinturino
bravo si dice così abbiamo come vediamo
un po il colore o scelto questo che è il
cinturino ma si toglie le già iscritti
torino grigio bianco ed è quello
vediamo come mi sta nella sua votazione
perché sono anche lui
noi facciamo bene e stiamo già facendo
youtube
eccolo qua allora se diamo un quadrante
assieme topolino minni posso che
scegliere il colore del vestito blu
celeste mettiamo rosa cori mettiamo un
celeste
c'è anche le porte riminesi mettiamo in
posta come quadrante eccola che carina
balla in che vediamo con gli altri si
sono caleidoscopio quante immagini che
pelle
però quello che mi piace di più è
sicuramente questo di mini micro vero
che dirige un bel mi piace se volete
vedere se monza l'engine berlino vuole
sempre essere il protagonista
io adesso non mi piace se volete vedere
la chat e giuste indovinate lo compro io
quattro cartellini sacrificare vedere
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite
ciao un filino
si no